turning around all the time yeah and
look at what's happened never never give
away the center for your opponent's
queen black's queen now is the dominant
piece
jordan he could have left his queen on a
great square stopping black's queen
occupied
is he planted a piece has he mouthful
he's just plundered a piece he's mouth
slipped tanish geary is it a mouse
slipper he wants to bring his queen to
the center and he's just lost his knight
i think he might have been a blunder i'm
not sure with the stress
oh that what about the clocks that is
crazy
look how upset he is is checkmate coming
out within a house i've never seen a
niche that upset anish geary he actually
just stops playing he is super upset
losing this game
with a mouse lip a blunder we're not
really just don't interview him now i'd
say this is one time
give him this piece
i have to say i've never seen anish
geary that upset after a game it's
traumatizing to lose in such a way and
it's such a critical moment as well
but decay
there's nothing for it he